beuzec millions d'abonnés à ma chaîne
youtube merci beaucoup c'est là pour
vous remercier je vais faire comme
d'habitude une petite vidéo alors j'ai
déjà répondu à vos questions je vous ai
déjà livrer des anecdotes sur moi même
maintenant je vais vous présenter des
objets celle où trouver sur internet
comme je suis pas le premier sur youtube
avoir eu cette idée certains d'entre
vous en dirons plus très original c'est
parti on ne veut pas vous le cacher la
plupart des objets que j'ai trouvé
viennent du japon que là bas on met de
la drogue dure dans les biberons des
nouveau-nés c'est en tout cas la seule
explication que j'ai trouvé à ce jour a
commencé avec des petits objets vous
savez j'adore le poisson il fallait donc
que je me procure une trousse en forme
de maquereau cadavre de mike rawstron
voit bien ses yeux totalement décédé au
petit détail sympathique qui va faire
fureur dans les écoles j'en doute pas à
l'intérieur il ya bien sûr les
entrailles du maquereau qui a envie de
voir ça tous les jours les écrans des
smartphones sont de plus en plus grand
avec ses dix m'ont poussé trop petit
pour ses écrans je vais donc créer une
extension de pouce exceptionnel parce
que déjà ça marche une fois sur sur
trois en plus ils ont mis un petit bout
de plastique noir pour que ce soit
tactile truc est tellement mal fait
qu'il pouvait pas faire le pouces
tactile fallait rajouter un truc
dégueulasse
nous sommes en 2015 ils ont ressorti
leur bille chewbacca d'accord fait un
bruit de chewbacca
d'ailleurs j'ai fait un bruit de
chewbacca comme une sorte de porte qui
s'ouvre je sais qu'ils dansent ceci
quand on fait de la musique au revoir
forbach à te plat ce fait il n'y a pas
de bras on arrive dans la partie
humiliante avec cet objet qui est une
sorte de boue je pense que c'est pour
muscler le visage bonjour c'est
extrêmement ils lisent l'isard enfin
nous que les gens si les femmes se
mettent ça pourrait être plus belles
faudra faire attention quand même penser
à l'enlever
blanchet rue on arrive à un moment que
j'aime beaucoup dans cette vidéo c'est
le moment musical avec cet objet qui
fait de la percussion ça fonctionne sur
un principe très très étrange quand on
appuie sur un joystick
ça fait des percussions que je suis un
peu de batterie donc je vais faire une
heure et mythe ça c'est parfois même
carrément un petit crochet pour
l'accrocher autour du cou gérait pas
jusque là alors je sais pas comment
décrire cet objet c'est une note de
musique avec des touches et nous bouche
qu'on appuie dessus ça fait du bruit
bref une démonstration sera plus parlant
rock mode
hier que ça veut dire
ça prend une mesure j'ai préféré vous
connaissez le bras de fer chinois avec
des poussées nul pourquoi pas faire un
bras de fer chinois avec des robots
c'est le premier quart va faire sauter
l'autre qui a gagné tout de suite une
démonstration ou le mien est fort ce
qu'il a des pouvoirs à l'épaule pour
faire life and death découle une bonne
patate
j'ai mis un peu plus sur le foulard à
faire venir saluer la bonté et je suis
déçu de ce qui est fait il a tout gagné
mais même bien gagner par tous les
autres jeux bon du coup maintenant que
j'ai fait venir stopper du japon je
propose qu'on fasse juste un brasseur
chinois et non par serge concret ce
qu'ils en vendent des pousse les états
membres qu'ils auront diamant est riche
et prendre le pouce pour le téléphone
mercy photo une autre utilité à chaque
objet 1 2 jours un instant sur la beauté
à la bouche c'était bien là c'est un
masque que les japonaises se mettre sur
la gueule pour j'imagine tirer les rides
est ce que j'aime bien c'est que en fait
ça fait un visage de grands brûlés quoi
un petit côté hannibal lecter
je pense que c'est nickel ces bons rôles
à à quel moment je dois être ses 10 ans
s'il vous plaît ne faites pas de
screenshot de sam suis respectueux
envers vous faites de même s'il vous
plaît si je met à l'envers
c'est ignoble j'ai envie de les percer
et ben je les paie t voilà assez cassé a
tous envie de s'allonger sur les gens
d'une femme nous passe sa main dans ses
cheveux
alors la main je n'ai pas mes parents
que les gens me disaient c'est un
oreiller le nombre de femmes qui
fonctionne de cette manière là voilà
comme ça franchement c'est pas trop mal
il ya juste quand on retourne on lui a
pété les chevilles on voit un bout de
pilotes également s'il vous plaît
larsson et pervers et 6,1 verra un petit
peu qu'elle a des penguins
la place des pierres fois il fait chaud
et on aimerait avoir un peu plus un peu
plus froid alors faut savoir que ces
duels
c est le japonais cette veste ressemble
à toutes les autres astuces n'est
qu'elle est beaucoup plus moche à un
détail près il fait chaud aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien avoir un peu plus froid
deux ventilateurs qui souffle dans la
baisse n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que
vous pensez de cette invention dans les
commentaires je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de penser aux mecs qui a eu l'idée de
cette veste le coup de tuninvest pour on
a trop chaud comme ça parfait elle
balance de l'air mais si tu as trop
chaud tu te mets en tee shirt enfin tu
mets où les ventilateurs je comprends
pas ton concept de t-shirts vois pas je
ne comprends pas par là j'ai un autre
vêtement au petit gilet sympa en lycra
et quoi une situation périlleuse
j'ai toujours j'avais d'autres années
déjà par contre c'est dommage parce que
ça tient chaud
abbas est beaucoup mieux revenir à la
beauté avec un masque qui empêche
d'avoir les yeux qui tombe mais aussi
une particularité te fais aussi
ressembler un super héros je suis le
premier super-héros ninja qui n'a pas
chaud qu'il n'a pas les yeux qui tombe
et ça c'est important au nom
un moustique il me faudrait une
moustiquaire juste pour moi
si seulement ça existait yes i
moustiquaires bonjour personnel je
ressors capote géante yes je pense que
c'est plus judicieux de faratea à je
sors tu m'as capote je voulais
profondément vous remercier pour les 8
millions d'abonnés oui c'est un
accoutrement ce normal pour remercier
les gens à ce que youtube c'est toute ma
vie faire plaisir aux internautes
essayer de vous faire rire de montrer
aussi des petits trucs qui font un peu
plus rêver comme l'aimé court métrage
d'ailleurs je bosse sur un prochain
court-métrage qui arriverait donc voilà
donc pas très très très très longtemps
ça me fait vibrer de créer ça pour vous
et encore merci d'être aussi nombreux à
me suivre merci beaucoup je vous dis à
très vite dans une prochaine vidéo on me
dira abonnez-vous mais 8 millions déjà
c'est exceptionnel